what did you do today YouTube is going
to teach us how to cut our own hair I'm
not as nervous as I probably should be
I'm scared shitless so let's see where
that goes the first 30 minutes we're
gonna be watching a tutorial video after
that we get 30 minutes to cut our own
hair and then right after we'll be going
around the office asking people how much
they think our haircut cost wait you're
not gonna take any notes you're just
going by memory oh yeah of course
do you I'm gonna I'm just let your head
relax no this is helping me at all
[Music]
are you scrubbing through your tutorials
yeah because I'm impatient I'm sorry are
you ready to cut your hair I have no
choice so hey that's yeah let's just get
this over with please I mean let's get
some air
thirty minutes starts now wow this just
got so real I'm doing my ponytail at the
top of my head
holy moly oh [ __ ] I'm gonna start with
the AIDS meaning that it's not gonna cut
that much why does this go
it's a literally just vibrating oh thank
you yeah I'm supposed to cut right above
this hair type here goes nothing it's
not going through it easily and I
thought it would suck my hair ok remove
this and make it into three sections
okay [ __ ] what am i doing you guys so
here's the one that I've like fixed a
little bit versus the one that has not
been fixed they feel like they look
better there's no going back now
it still looks pretty blunt I'm going to
do what I just did over how much time do
we have 717 back how do they do this I
mean it gets a little rough over here oh
my gosh oh my gosh I like don't know how
to fix this
now I'm straight from the tutorial I'm
just going by memory the last time I got
my haircut in August I'm just trying to
remember what my hairstylist does but I
don't think he's ever [ __ ] up my hair
this bad she definitely hasn't she's
wonderful at her job we have two full
minutes you know what [ __ ] it I'll just
have to go to this side because this
looks
right here this long we started yeah
okay so it looks like I only cut this
much and this stuff right here is just
hanging out I think I feel a lot more
confident on this side I think it's
gonna look way better on my left on the
right side oh yeah okay now I'm getting
a hang of this well I'm not I'm just
gonna there goes my hair it's on the
ground now if I should just give up on
my back this is not what this is
supposed to look like you guys I know
what a haircut supposed to look like if
it doesn't it okay well I think I give
up now so well I can't really give up
because at least I want to look decent
when I come out here maybe it's
something where our co-workers will not
no no please be merciful hey though arms
going on it's not like totally even but
I don't think it's as bad as you think
it does compare this side okay to this
side that side looks much better well
here's my hair honestly like if I look
from far away oh wait before we've asked
anybody their opinions would you do this
again definitely not I absolutely would
not I think I learned my lesson
I've learned my lesson but I don't know
I'm excited to see what our co-workers
have said I'm not how much do I think
you paid for your haircut seventy
dollars I cut it myself okay now that
you point it out yeah it's a little
blood it definitely smells like it was
below blow-dried so you think you've got
it done this was your regular hair smell
damn you have been smelling it
okay smells like you just showered okay
I think they're I think your low-end
haircut are they the same or different I
think you did them yourselves
the only reason is that there's one
little part that's like not fully
blended a little uneven in the back
yours looks great but also a little
uneven did you like do these to each
other to yourselves that's impressive
like honestly Wow
yeah it definitely they definitely don't
look like expensive hair
[Music]
[Applause]